This edition of Scoutmasters podcast is brought to you by the folks in Conahoe Creek. out there,
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prizes for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreekcom.
That's c-o-n-o-h-o-creekcom.
And now for you, Scoutmasters.
And they are usually so relieved that somebody came up with an idea
that they'll jump on it like a dog on a bone, really work to carry it out
and they'll put their own. you know, they'll put their own spin on it.
Got dog's berry bones.
Every metaphor breaks down at some point.
Not the metaphor.
Yes, every metaphor breaks down at some point.
I'm trying to insert a little folk wisdom.
All right, Walter,
Here you are.
Hey, this is podcast number 154..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Greene.
Let's take a look at the mailbag. See who got in touch this past week.
We heard from Antelope, California, from Jeff Berg, who's Scoutmaster of Troop 22..
He said I just finished listening to the Scout Circle Hangout
concerning the STEM NOVA program.
Thank you for putting this together.
Thank you.
He said I just finished listening to the Scout Circle Hangout
concerning the STEM NOVA program.
Thank you for putting this on.
I'll be challenging our older Scouts to create a program
that can be implemented for our younger Scouts
and presented to the associated pack.
I'll let you know how it goes.
Thanks, Clark, for all you're doing for us Scouters.
I for one can say I'm a better Scoutmaster because of the podcast.
Keep up the great work.
Thanks so much, Jeff. I always appreciate hearing from people.
I'm glad you were able to get something out of our Scout Circle presentation.
I'll talk a little bit more about that in a moment.
Glenn got in touch and there was a post this past week
about keeping older Scouts active
and I used an old picture of one of our backpacking trips
to illustrate that post
And Glenn said: your picture for that post made me laugh.
It must be a standard pose.
I've sent you a photo of my son doing exactly that
on a high-class fall.
Yes, I think that pose, which is standing on a rock
and looking out over the valley and pointing
you know, comes from the old LL Bean catalogs
or something like that, is pretty familiar
And for some reason it is a pose that boys adopt
whenever they get to a high place.
I did mention Scout Circle there
and we recorded our first live Scout Circle
just yesterday evening
and it was about the Scouting's STEM NOVA program
And if you'd like to see that, it has been recorded
and it is available for viewing over at scoutscircleorg
And you can go over. take a look at the video
and we'd love to get some feedback about these presentations.
I'm working with Scouter Arlen Ward
Been working to put this together
and see what we can come up with.
come up with this kind of virtual roundtable experience
where we can get people who really know their subject-
and they wouldn't necessarily be available
to a local roundtable- to come and speak.
We think we might be able to do some pretty great stuff.
So our next one will be in February,
on the second Sunday in February.
So keep an eye on scoutscirclecom
and we'll keep you apprised of upcoming live events.
I checked in again with Bill Fleming this week
and let me share that with you. now
I've got Bill Fleming from Conahoe Creek on the phone again.
Conahoe Creek is a sponsor of the podcast.
How you doing, Bill?
Doing great, Clark, How are you doing?
I got a look at this new thing you put together
called the Scout Gear Bundle
and I got to say I'm impressed.
It looks like everything that a new Scout needs
to be able to go camping.
That's exactly what it is.
These are things that will help you
with some of the advancement requirements
that you're going to face as you get into scouting
and work towards first class.
So I think it's a great idea,
because what usually happens is a new Scout gets a gear list
and then he and his folks go out
and they try and find stuff
and they're not too sure
they don't have the expertise to be able to pick the stuff out
and they end up with things that don't work so well.
So putting together this bundle is a great idea.
Let's talk about one of the pieces of it.
For instance, I know one thing that if I tell my Scouts
that they need a compass,
they might go and get a discount store compass
or something like that. that may be inexpensive,
but it's not going to work very well.
And in the Scout Bundle,
one of the things you have in it
is a really great Silver 1-2-3 compass.
Tell me a little bit about that.
Yeah, the Silver 1-2-3 is a very basic compass.
However, real often you'll find advanced Scouts
using that type of compass.
It's good for map work as well as in the field
when you're getting ready to actually work a compass course
And, being a Silver compass,
it comes with a great guarantee.
It will give you great years of service,
And that's just one of the selections
that's made in this gear bundle.
There's a first-aid kit and a sleeping bag
and a sleeping pad and a headlamp
and all kinds of stuff
that we won't take time to talk about right now.
But go on over to ConahoeCreekcom.
I think it's a great idea
and I think it's just like having a personal shopper
with a lot of experience. help you pick out gear
that's going to last a long time
and that is going to serve you very well,
And also keep looking out.
We're going to continue to build bundles
based on different needs that people have.
Bill, you'll customize this any way people want right.
You'll use your expertise to help them choose
the right gear for their particular climate.
and just because it's in the scout bundle
doesn't mean it has to stay in there.
You'll switch things out and do whatever they need
to get them the gear that they really want, right?
Oh, absolutely.
In fact, we've had several people
already contact us this week
wanting to get items
switched around a little bit,
or even one inquired about an item
we didn't even have
and we were able to get it for them.
So that's what we're all about at ConahoeCreek.
Well, thanks, Bill.
Everybody get yourselves over to ConahoeCreekcom-
C-O-N-O-H-O-Creekcom,
and when you get ready to check out,
use the special coupon code
for listeners to the Scoutmaster podcast:
C-G-1-1-3..
So in this podcast,
finally, we have our first
Scoutmaster panel discussion of the year
and we got a guest and everything.
It was a wonderful time
and I really appreciate everybody's time
in recording that,
and that's going to be coming up in just a moment
and we'll revise the remainder of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another
Scoutmaster panel discussion.
Well, it's time for yet another
Scoutmaster panel discussion,
The first one of 2013,
and we have the usual suspects assembled.
Tom Gillard is down in Tolahoma, Tennessee.
Hello, Tom,
Hello.
Happy New Year to everyone.
Happy New Year, Tom.
And Larry Geiger is in Vera, Florida.
How you doing, Larry,
Good,
Hey guys.
And Walter Underwood is
in the tall trees out there in California,
out there in Palo Alto.
How you doing, Walter,
Doing good.
And this time around,
we have a guest with us
and Maury is from Northern California.
Hello, Maury,
Hello.
I've heard from Maury through email
a little while back
and I asked him to join us
and he has some questions for us
about the coming of Scoutmaster.
So, Maury, give us a little background,
Tell us a little bit about the troop
you'd be taking over.
Okay,
Well, actually I'm officially
Scoutmaster now.
Oh, you are.
It happened last night.
So our troop is chartered
through the American Legion.
We have 47 boys
And we've got lots of ASMs,
lots of committee members.
The boys' leadership positions
are pretty well filled
and they function pretty well,
although patrol leader always seems
to be one of the hardest jobs
to get to work effectively.
Generally, our boys' leadership
positions are for a year.
We do a planning meeting
in late August
and the boys meet every month
for a patrol leader council meeting
to plan for the following month.
I think our troop is about 20 years old.
That's a good size troop
with 47 boys in it.
Yeah,
Something's going right.
Here we are, fellas.
We've gone to the roundtable
or we're hanging out at summer camp
and somebody has a brand new Scoutmaster
and we want to give them
words of encouragement.
What's your best advice, fellas?
How about we start with Tom?
Well, right now it sounds like
you've come in on the top of the wave
and everything's doing real well,
and the hard part will be
to keep it that way,
to let the boys-
I'm on the bottom of the wave right now,
Keeping the boys on task,
doing what you're doing.
It sounds like things are flowing real well for you.
The question that I would have
is where you want to go with your plan,
and you're going to have to kind of decide
if you want to drift along
or if you want to draw a line
and just start over.
My first idea would be
to just start the whole thing over again,
Have a new annual planning conference,
Do some training of my own,
Get to know the older Scouts.
I think you need to be really careful
about just kind of drifting through
the rest of the spring
and not dealing with some of this,
if that's what you want to do.
So kind of hitting the reset button.
Well, possibly, yes,
Yeah. so, Walter,
what would you say to a guy
who talks up to you and says that
they just got to be the scout master?
Ooh, condolences, congratulations.
It's going to be more work than you expected,
but especially because it's so hard
keeping your hands in your pockets
and letting the other guys do it badly,
which is the only way you learn
is: you can't learn from success
because you don't know what worked right.
So I would pick
a really small number of things,
like one or two, maybe three,
expecting that they're not all going to change.
if you want to get, say,
outings on a regular basis
and patrol camping on outings,
Just a couple of things.
It may take a long time for those to happen.
And then troop leadership training:
sit down with SPL patrol leaders,
have them set goals,
see if the SPL has things they want to do.
Maybe they have a better idea.
Mentor a little bit in the direction
of some things. you see that would help.
And when you're in doubt,
let the program roll.
What was your position prior to last night
and was this amicable?
Were you the first choice
or how did you become the scout master last night?
I've been involved with this troop since 2002..
There have been rocky times in the past,
but I would say over the last five, six years
the ASMs and the boys
and the committee have been working very well together
And I think for the most part
we adults have been fairly effective
in not trampling on the boys.
I was committee chair until 2009,
and since then I've been an assistant scout master.
I've sat in on a good number
of the patrol leader council meetings
So I have a fairly good rapport
with the boys and the current leaders
and I kind of understand what their style is.
And again, I already have gotten a lot of practice
trying to keep my hands in my pockets
and keep my mouth shut
so the boys can do their work.
But I'm not coming at this completely cold
and I have a relationship with the boys
and the leaders already, luckily.
You asked about the transition.
The transition was completely amicable.
Our previous scout master was doing a good job.
His youngest son is starting as a Tiger Cub
so he needs to kind of refocus his efforts
and he'd finished a three-year tenure.
We went through the standard process
looking for a new scout master
and I put my name in.
I don't know what order I was.
If you follow the process
as it's written in the BSA rules, you don't know.
And to be honest, it wouldn't matter
because I'm the scout master now,
regardless of how many candidates they went through.
Oh, you're stuck, brother.
Yeah,
One of the things that I've seen.
I'll get a lot of boys tell me
I did the square knot for this rank,
or I learned the clothe hitch for this rank
so I don't need to do that anymore.
Well, I know what I'd like to have happen,
but I've been concerned for a long time
that the attitude is: I did that requirement,
I'm done, I never have to worry about it again.
I was just curious about your comments on that.
Okay, That's a pep one for Larry.
Watch out.
If they're going to be Star Life or Eagle,
they're going to take a position of responsibility
and you guys have heard this before.
It's their job to lead, train and inspire
those younger scouts to achieve first class
and part of that job is teaching them those skills.
You know there's different ways to do that:
within the patrols or with instructor positions.
I never was good at backing off of that.
I kept telling them face to face. on some occasion
some of the older scouts- that's your job, you know,
And I mean the senior patrol leader-
would pick out two guys and say:
you know, you 16-year-old scout,
you go, take those two 11-year-olds,
learn Bolans or First Aid.
I mean you have to make it part of the culture of your troop
that that's what they do.
Everybody who's first class. it's their job
to be doing that stuff and it becomes a habit,
It becomes part of what your troop does.
As they teach the skills, they become real to them,
not just, oh, I did that,
It starts to become theirs to some extent
Life has. you must do a list of requirements
using the EDGE method,
which is teaching others to do these skills,
And we've kind of come around.
I understand how many times can you tie a square knot?
But if you make a little game out of it,
like take a tent and strip all the ropes off it
and then have them pitch the tent,
well, lookie here, this is where this knot goes,
and oh, this line's not long enough to reach this tree.
so now we need to use a square knot to tie a longer line
and make it more real-time or real-life uses
for each of those knots and the advancements.
Well, we're lucky that we do have that culture
where the older scouts teach.
We do a lot of that scout skills instruction
in patrol meetings.
So we have a patrol meeting
Once. one night a month is the patrol meeting night,
And so the patrol leader is the one whose job it is
to get those other scouts to teach.
In troop leadership training.
I taught EDGE to the patrol leaders.
Some of them have set goals for
we want this many guys to advance,
Well, they need other guys to teach them
to get through that advancement.
My question, Maury,
is what percentage of instruction are scouts doing
And on the other side,
what percentage are adults doing? Clark,
In the last few years
they've been working very hard on having the boys
do all the training.
One thing that seems to have happened
is that we have troop guides and instructors
and so they become the ones that do the training
and meet with the younger boys,
but the other older boys just kind of feel like
they've got to pass.
Maybe our problem is not building the general culture
for boys first class and up.
But are adults instructing
For the most part? no, not anymore.
Okay, All right.
And who's signing off requirements?
ASMs can sign off requirements.
For the most part, our troop guides
are signing off on requirements up to first class.
You said you had fairly well-distributed patrols.
You could work on the culture that Walter's talking about
within that kind of a thing.
In my troops I've always had any scout
whose first class can work with you
on any requirement up to first class.
Any scout that's first class and above
should be doing some teaching
as part of their car and life ranks.
Okay, that's a good idea.
I have one question for Walter to follow up on.
Did Walter say that one troop night a month
is a patrol night?
That's right. One of the weekly meetings
is a patrol meeting and the patrols decide
where that is: the house, the rec room,
the apartment building or whatever.
The troop meeting plan has a time for patrol meetings.
I think the monthly patrol meeting
really forces the patrol leader.
There's not a bunch of scoutmasters standing around it.
I like that thing, Walter.
It really pushes them into their position.
It gives them a great opportunity
to actually do what they're up to.
Are you saying one of the nights
that would be a troop night
is instead when the patrols get together?
or you're just saying you make sure
patrols meet once a month at least?
No, it's regular troop meeting night.
You can already call your patrol leader
to find out where it is.
At the PLC meeting,
the SPL talks with the patrol leaders
about what they're going to do that night.
At the next meeting they talk about
what they did last time.
We do a similar thing.
All the patrols meet at the same place.
They meet at the church
where we have our regular troop meetings.
They do that at least once a month
and sometimes twice,
Suspending the troop meeting night,
putting it in the hands of the patrol leaders.
it's been good for everybody.
We have had patrol leaders
who decided to just go for the
National Honor Patrol
Because that actually has a nice.
that means you have two meetings a month.
They'll get the patrol together
at the end of the scout meeting
or sometimes say: okay, this is a meeting
and we're talking about what we're cooking
on the camp out.
You have to have people advance
coverage of what a patrol should be doing.
A good number of years ago
we seemed to have a lot more variety
in our troop meetings.
The boys seemed to have gotten stuck in a rut
and had very few ideas,
Very few original ideas, about
what they should be doing in troop meetings.
I suspect part of it is they're
really not working the program much anymore.
I wanted to get some ideas about
the universe of activities
that they might want to consider
for working in a troop meeting.
What I find is generally
our troop meeting plans
are driven by the outing
and whatever we're getting
ready to do that month
they're prepping for during troop meetings.
whatever skills
or other preparations
need to be made are all centered on
what's happening that month
where we're going camping
and what they have planned to do.
What's it like in your troop, Tom?
We're doing the same thing.
we've got the district campery
coming up and we know ahead of time
what the theme is.
There's a world of things right there.
but have you seen
the Wood Wisdoms
book?
Our senior patrol leaders have it.
I've never been able to get them to actually read it
or use it. It's got a lot of good ideas.
some of them are hard to implement,
but that's
a good place to start too.
The troop program helps.
the three-year plan is
one place. have them
pick a theme and then do the meetings
At some point. our guys started
doing monthly themes,
so they'll at the beginning,
at the annual planning meeting,
they'll decide on monthly things. Some of them are
things like:
we have the new guys showing up
in March and so
we need to do a thing about backpacking
and stuff like that so they'll be ready to go in outings.
Some of them we've got to do
first aid at some point, so there's a lot of stuff that gets repeated.
We do sing on winter
camping and clothing and hypothermia
every year. The monthly themes
do help. Again,
I've not been able to get anybody that interested
in the troop program features.
I have occasionally
got them to use the games.
it's a great list of games.
When we're looking at the why
of a troop meeting, you know, if
we don't have a why behind
what we're doing, I think sometimes
we lose the spirit of it
and guys
and scouts just kind of- you know,
well, I've already tied a square knot,
we've already done this, let's find something new to do.
but why are they doing it in the first place?
one of the reasons is while
we're getting ready to go camping,
and the other one is, you know
the phrase that I
have adopted from Larry,
that I suggest to everyone,
and that is a
scouts job
becomes a first class. scout is to
lead, train and inspire
other scouts to become first class.
if that becomes the watch word
for these guys,
then they have something
to point at. and it's
a continual goal and it always
renews itself because there's always somebody new.
you know, does your PLC
talk about what
works and didn't work in the previous meetings?
because ours guys
they all occasionally say, wow, that was the
worst meeting that they've ever had.
that does get discussed
and sometimes it's not just
last meeting, it's,
you know, something's brought up,
people say, oh, that didn't work,
oh, yeah, we love that.
so there is some institutional
memory and there is some
discussion and argument back and forth
and I try to be really quiet
when I start hearing that kind of stuff,
because they're actually doing their job.
well, that's where you could
tell:
talk to the SPL
about stop, start, continue
about to take that what worked and say,
okay, quick, guys, which we stop doing,
start doing, continue doing and make notes,
subscribe makes notes.
yeah, but also boys are boring.
you know, from about
12 and a half till about 16,
you know that they can just sleep and eat all
day long. I mean,
you know, sometimes
we need to challenge them.
you know you just have to say: well,
you know, we're going canoeing
with the senior patrol or the PLC
guys, we really need
to hit the water. you know you need
to plan on how to do that,
train on that, spend the weekend
in a canoe and you don't want to run
their program, but occasionally
it is your job to kind of inspire
them. we have this with outings
where the guys are
really bad at imagining
some place they haven't been. I think it's just
a skill you learn later.
the SPL we have now have a rule
we've used for a while,
which is that
what is a third of outings
have to be some place. you didn't go
last year, so because otherwise I go,
let's go back to Castle Rock and then
after four years, are going. no, it's really boring
in Castle Rock.
so
you're both exactly right,
they cannot
see outside that box,
they cannot see outside the city
hardly, and
you have to push them.
but you have to throw those,
some of these things into the list, into the pot,
and they go: oh, where'd that come from?
and maybe they'll do it.
I'm the blog and on the podcast. we talk about the patrol method
constantly, we talk about the importance
of the autonomy of youth leadership
constantly, and sometimes
I think that people
see that as kind of an
on off switch.
either we do this all the way
or we don't do it at all.
you know we tried this and the boys sat around
at a patrol leaders council meeting and they couldn't come up with any good ideas.
our job,
as Larry said and as Walter said
and as Tom said, sometimes is to
throw that idea on the table
and say: I think
you guys ought to try this,
and they are usually so relieved
that somebody came up
with an idea
and they jump on it like a dog on a bone,
really work to carry it out
and they'll put their own
spin on it.
I'm a little concerned that right now our troop
was focused too much on advancement
and doesn't really have enough
enthusiasm for scouting
or outdoor skills. you know,
which is what Baden Powell said
was the whole point of the program.
this is an area where I'm really not sure
there hasn't been a lot of effort to try to
really develop a backpacking culture.
leave them at home.
if your first backpacking trip is,
six scouts and three adults go,
and if everybody, if 40 guys stay
home that weekend, go
and when you get back see what happens
when those six guys come back.
you know you don't have to build every
single activity around every
single scout in the troop.
somebody's going to stay home.
we've gone with just three scouts
before.
we gave them the opportunity to back out.
we got there and
I think there were
six and three of them didn't show,
so it left three and they go. no, we want to
go and we said let's go.
so three scouts and three adults
went backpacking
and they had a great time
and they did come back and they told them
they had a great time
and that may be how Walters troop got started.
20 years ago
we did a film on
Shakedown Dayhike with two adults.
you know
people got busy or whatever. like: let's go,
I got a walk, I'm going to be left behind.
to film on
advancement and
requirements and things like that
are
to scouting, what
doing drills is, to a sport.
they don't want to just throw a basketball
back and forth or practice
three point shots all day.
they want to actually play the game.
you know you may suggest that to them
that you know you guys are kind of caught up
in doing the drills
and you're missing the whole game.
let's go out and play,
let's go hiking, let's get out in the woods,
let's go camping. the heck with all
that other stuff. you know, forget
about the advancement. see if
that appeals to them. when you do the
things that scouts do, they advance.
if you go camping
or you go backpacking or you go canoeing
or you go on a good hike,
they're doing things towards
advancement, but they're not doing it
because they're
going to advance. they're doing it because
it's what scouts do. does that make
any sense? yeah,
yeah it does.
this was alluded to
earlier on,
our planning meeting didn't work very well.
what ended up
happening for as far as I can tell, is
most of the boys came completely
unprepared, with no ideas, so
sounded like it was a situation where they
they couldn't really imagine themselves
anywhere. well, this is where you
go to the senior patrol and you start
asking them some questions. but when you
start asking them questions about the
arrangements that they have made and the
practicalities involved, they begin
to wake up to that a little bit.
this sounds like I'm headed in another direction,
but tell me a little bit about your patrol
leaders council. and when they meet,
they actually meet on a troop night.
the senior patrol leader,
the patrol leader and all other leadership
attend. the boys, you know,
work through an agenda
of the things that they need to talk about.
so part of it is planning,
part of it's planning troop meetings and part of it's
talking about upcoming events.
so how many scouts are at that? meaning?
actually a lot. I would say
10 to 15 boys,
okay, and some of
them aren't patrol leaders, obviously.
oh no, not at all. we only have four patrols,
okay. and how many adults are at that?
meaning there are three regular
adult attendees? the scout master
I would attend,
and we also have another assistant
scout master whose job
is to make sure that
boys are showing up. you know they're
actually doing something in terms of their leadership
requirement for their higher ranks,
okay, so let me suggest this to you:
trim that patrol leaders
council down
dramatically. you have your senior
patrol leader,
yeah, the senior patrol leader,
assistant senior patrol leader
and the patrol leaders. that's it.
maybe the scribe, maybe the scribe,
maybe the quarter master-
I think we have the quarter master and the scribe
at most of ours
and they get together
and they make the plan
and then
they work with
whoever else is going to be involved in that plan.
and the reason I suggest
this is that
with a group that large,
it's going to be really, really difficult for them
to focus
and to
actually arrive at decision points.
oh, yeah, yeah, I've seen that.
so, yeah, trim that group down
and keep all the adults, including yourself, out of the room,
talk to them a little bit
ahead of time and say, okay, so
what are your expectations for this meeting?
and you may have to add one
or two to begin with
and say, okay, so when you're done,
let me know,
and I would just like you
to review what you've planned with me
very quickly at the end of the meeting
and
the other guys who are involved
in leadership positions
and things like that.
you'll have to create something else
for them to do.
if you focus a smaller group
on those plans,
it's going to set a precedent so that when you come around
to an annual planning conference
they're more focused on what they're up to
more. what I would do is
I'd sit down on my SPL
one-on-one and I would chat with him,
tell him that the next PLC meeting,
these are the six guys I want you to have,
and then I would sit down
in that meeting. I would talk to the PLS
and SPL
and say: look, you guys are the leaders.
here's your responsibilities,
here's some things I'd like to see.
let's talk about our schedule,
because there's some
problems and issues. and
15 guys at a PLC meeting-
that's just way too big for your SPL
and your patrol leaders.
they're just lost in the noise.
the other thing that
I know that we're probably not going to get
your whole list of questions here.
fine, this has all been really useful.
the other thing I would suggest
with the patrol leaders council
is the once a month meeting.
that's excellent.
a lot of people don't even get
that.
I would suggest that
you, if you're not already
doing it, that you have
the- you know the 10 or 15 minutes
before every meeting
and the 10 or 15 minutes
after every meeting. the patrol leaders council
is just expected to get together
and sometimes that's
five minutes of standing there
and saying: how did everything go?
what did you learn that you need
to change next time?
what would you adjust?
what was real successful?
I saw you guys doing this
and it was fantastic and
a big pat on the back for that.
I know that when we started doing that
many years ago,
that really helped to jumpstart
their initiative
and they were constantly getting together.
we've been really lucky in our troop.
when boys stand for
senior patrol leader,
they make a serious commitment and they're there.
however,
you know you've got band,
you've got sports,
you've got other things that have
seasonal components to them.
what do you do if a scout stands for
election and you know they're
going to have commitments where they're
just not going to be there for a long
period of time?
I've actually had this happen with
patrol leaders. you know, basically
decapitating the patrol
in the middle of the year
and things start to drift. if that's
one thing I would say is that
whatever you guys want to do,
but a year is probably
too long,
we have elections twice a year.
the guys can have elections anytime.
they can have elections
tomorrow.
it's their patrol,
it's their troop.
we have twice a year,
normally twice a year, elections.
say, one of the patrol leaders
has a sudden commitment
that starts not showing up, sort of like Larry,
they say, well, we don't have a patrol leader,
we'll fix that problem.
and
for the senior patrol leaders,
when,
when the elections come up,
I ask everyone
that wants to throw their hat in the ring to come
see me
and I go through, I get the book out
and I say: these are your responsibilities.
what other commitments do you have
in the next six months?
you will have the time to do that
and they may or may not say
yes,
but anyway I sort of
lead them through
the requirements of what it's going to take
to be senior patrol leader,
especially the senior patrol leader.
we get tied into schedules
of elections sometimes,
and when I say we, I mean adults.
it becomes a habit
and that forms an expectation
in the boys.
I'm all in favor
of especially patrol leader
positions being a lot more fluid.
one of the reasons is because
they do have a lot of commitments that we want
to see them keep outside of scouting,
to give them the
flexibility so that they can do
that without feeling like they've
let somebody down or
they've backed out of a commitment.
hey, you know, if you've got to spend the next
three months
of Tuesday nights at marching band,
that's no harm, no foul.
we want you to have fun at marching band.
it's just time for somebody else to
have the patrol leader spot.
and you know
the senior patrol leader. it's a little bit different
and they
should go into it knowing that
it's a pretty serious commitment.
and maybe the question to
ask them more is: do you think
a year is too long,
or would you guys rather see us
change the senior patrol leader every six months,
for instance?
and you know, let them
chew on that for a while.
we have discussed this with the boys
and they said they liked the year
because they said:
I agree it's a long time.
they say that
the first six months
they're learning the position and the last six months
they're actually doing the position.
but
it is a year.
for a boy who's
14,, 15,, 16- a year
it's a significant portion of his life.
yeah,
it's almost a 14,, 15th or 16th
of it.
yeah, we have.
we have six months of terms
and but
the SPL almost always
serves two terms
and it is that kind of thing where you learn
and then you do it.
I think part of it is
with patrol leaders, especially
in the first
really big job they've had,
and it's the most important job in the troop-
to make sure that they know
that you can't lead
if you're not there.
patrol leaders are expected to be on campouts
and this is the thing where you do have
expectations. these are the expectations
you know. if it's been
a couple of campouts, you're going to sit down right away
and say these are the expectations for your position.
in case you're not really not clear,
in some cases you could say
what's your position.
it's one of the more
constant tasks
for a scout master
is keeping-
I don't want to say riding herd
on youth leaders,
but just keeping up with them
and helping them
understand the commitment
and then also
helping them
shape that commitment so it fits.
and if our goal
is a consistent leadership
for a term of six months,
well then we're going to do things differently.
but if our goal is
to provide opportunities to young men
to try these things out
and to discover something about them.
I think we can be a lot more fluid
with the way that they're administered.
there's nobody too young to be a patrol leader.
if he's elected,
then he's old enough
and you have to
just keep pushing
the patrol thing
and then you're just going to start looking
for every way that you can
to pull the assistant scout masters
out of the boys campsites.
you just don't stop.
you don't ever give up,
and it is not an easy thing
to watch chaos
but to understand that learning
is happening.
really, the difference between success
and failure so far as a patrol leader
is concerned, as a trick of perspective,
our ideal of what
looks like a successful
patrol leader
and what is actually successful
for that individual boy
are two very different things.
I would be a little surprised
if a 12 or 13 year old patrol leader
was hyper competent.
they're pretty messy,
they're pretty unprepared most of the time.
but what did you say
towards the beginning of our discussion, Walter?
you don't learn from success.
my son was a patrol leader
for a year and a half.
the very last patrol meeting
he actually wrote down a plan.
he said: hey, that worked,
that's a success.
absolutely,
absolutely small steps. sometimes
we do that with SPL,
but maybe you should have been for a year and a half-
and those small steps
are what you use to
keep them moving forward
and to step upon
the next small step.
success for them to
work on and just keep growing from there.
Mori, have we hit everything
that you hope to hit, or is there
anything that you were
especially interested in finding out about?
you know, I think we've touched on,
we've touched on a lot of things
and it's given me some fresh
ideas and perspectives also,
so I'm very excited.
good, well, it's an exciting ride,
that's for sure.
interesting, if nothing else.
well, I'll make one
personal suggestion.
that is, to find something you like to do
in scouting
and make sure you do that,
whether it's having adults eat good food on camp
outs or shooting sports
or just something,
and have that happen.
you know, Mori, I
say this over and over again-
the guys are tired of hearing me, but you know, one day
you have a son in the troop, right,
yes, yeah, one day
you're going to be walking
down the trail
and this 17 year old,
160 pound guy is going to
walk up next to you and put his arm around you
and your sweat is going to be running off
your brow and you're going to be feeling too old
for this and go down and go
how you doing? dad
came by to check on you
and to see if you're okay.
you know putting them in charge
and doing this over and over again,
and that will happen
and you will absolutely know
exactly why. you just said yes
last night.
and congratulations on that,
Mori. I hope we've been able to help you a little bit.
there's always lots of things
to talk about in a subject like this
and we love to talk,
but I guess we have to all go to bed
at some point. so
thank you so much for joining us this evening.
thank you,
and I'm going to keep listening to the podcast.
it's a lot of fun to listen to.
and, Walter, you need
to keep an eye
on the snow pack out there.
I hear avalanches
or something. am I wrong?
we have a nice snow pack
and, who knows, maybe I'll run into Mori
and his troop on the slopes of Mount Diablo.
maybe snow there.
snow level is going to be
1500 feet this weekend.
well, thanks very much, Walter, for joining us again.
and, Tom, how's
the snow pack in Tennessee,
it's very light
for 2 or 3 inches of rain in this.
well, thanks so much for joining us again. Tom,
thanks a lot. see you later.
and Larry,
the man who does not know snow.
no, it was 81 degrees
on the patio this evening,
but it was a beautiful
sunset over the Indian river.
no, as a matter of fact, no snow,
no snow. and I thank you, Clark.
thank you, Larry, thanks for joining us again,
and I've got to tell you there's no snow here
either, but you know, we hold out hope.
it's only January.
thanks once more, guys, and
I really appreciate your time.
well, thanks for listening.
and here's how to keep in touch.
you can read the scout master
blog at
scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can
subscribe to receive updates
to the blog and the podcast by email.
you can subscribe to this podcast,
the scout master podcast, on iTunes.
you can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through
Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you get details on how to do that
at stitchercom.
you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us
at scoutmaster blog on Facebook
or tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle
search for us on google plus.
now, if what I just said
was absolutely, completely meaningless to you
and you are not part of
the vast panorama of social media,
how about email?
you can always do that.
email me, Clark Green,
your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, you know, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
so before we leave you, let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert, good luck to you
and group happy
why. thank you, sir, until next time
you.